I'm Soroush Vosoughi.
I'm a postdoc at the MIT Media Lab.
I also did my PhD at MIT, and I've been a
fellow here at Berkman since September.
The question I'm really interested in and
what I'm working on as a fellow at Berkman
and also as a postdoc at MIT Media Lab is
interventions to dampen the effects of misinformation
on social media.
My PhD focused on automatic detection of rumors
Right now I'm interested in intervention strategies,
so one idea I have is maybe an automated tool
like a bot on Twitter and on Facebook that
would detect misinformation using the algorithm
I developed for my thesis.
And then contact people who are on the path
of the misinformation to let them know that
they might be exposed to this thing.
Kind of vaccinating them before they're actually
exposed to the virus of misinformation.
Now I think it's become pretty obvious that
rumors and misinformation in different domains
are super important, and damaging to society,
specifically rumors in the political domain.
They undermine the core democratic values
of our society, because if you don't have
a shared truth with the other people who are
voting in the same election as you then you're
not judging the candidates based on the same
facts.
I think technology is always neutral, almost
always neutral.
So it can be used for good or evil.
What excites me, and what makes me fearful
is actually the same technology, which is
specifically recent advances in deep neural
networks.
A lot of the problems in classical AI have
already been solved using this new method
in the last decade, so problems that we thought
we would not be able to solve in a century
we've already solved.
So that's really exciting.
But again, the same algorithms and systems
that we've used to solve these problems, they're
big black boxes.
We never know exactly what goes in them.
And so if you give them too much power to
govern our society, they might actually make
decisions that we would never understand,
and that we'll never be able to interpret
— and that scares me.